one of them's always weak what did I say
what did I say bro making me sound like
I spice what did I say bro what did I
say bro you might not hearing me what
did I say bro
[Music]
we're back with another Banger guys as
you know how we do you know but the bomb
at the bomb but the bomb as he says
um yeah back with another Banger we go
straight in with the IG question and I
had your question of this week was
what's something that's happened that's
made you think this can't be real life
simulation Theory okay first one fast
and furious five
[Laughter]
enough I saw a video
can't remember when it was probably a
few months ago of some some English guy
I think it was on Tick Tock or it was on
Twitter but I was a tick tock video
um some white brother he was laughing at
all the different titles of fast of the
fast franchise oh okay because none of
them match up swear none of them match
up I don't even know their names bro all
right let's run through it let's Okay
cross franchise let me type in real
quick none of whatever none of them
match up it was hilarious
curious much yourself
no but I'm saying in relation to any of
the other ones so like the far is one is
called the the first one is called The
Fast and the Furious the second one is
called Too Fast Too Furious the third
one is called uh Jeff right the third
one is called The Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift the fourth one is called
Fast and Furious yeah yeah yeah yeah the
fifth one is called Fast Five
the sixth one is called Fast and Furious
six so there's no continuation yeah the
seventh one is called furious seven oh
God the eighth one is called the fate of
the theorists are not like f8 but
f-a-t-e the fate of the Furious I didn't
even know that what you call that the
ninth one is called F9
and the last one that's coming out is
called Fast X so fast 10. bro none of
them have like continuity yes Vin Diesel
just says and does he does what he wants
this is it's his only bag yes
a few residuals coming in yeah
pitch black that's a movie by the way
yeah yeah well he was inside a house
he's got another like van is it Van
Helsing no he's not financing he's got
another Trilogy where he's like a he's a
killer I'm sure he's a killer something
similar to like um is it still you talk
about the same thing from Pitch Black
because you got Pitch Black and then
you've got there's a there's a prequel
The Chronicles of Riddick Chronicles of
Riddick that's the one I was thinking
it's a prequel to pitch black I'm sure
yeah it is
Chronicles of Riddick yeah bro that's
the one I was thinking that's when Vin
Diesel was a man yeah yeah that's when
Vin dies was a was a map who else could
we compare him with back in though back
in the days
um who was doing up action back in them
days 2004 2004 there's three Rocks come
up in it yeah Rock was still wrestling
so he was doing like them Disney type
yeah he was in that mid-range where like
[Music]
it was just him and jokey joke Terry
Crews
wow yeah yeah there was no one that was
fighting yeah
and he had a voice on him yeah yeah oh
distinctive facts yeah okay say less LS
um do you know random actually no get
back to this I'll talk about it do you
know what's the most underrated action
film of all time that's a statement
first of all do you know what it is no
blade one bro I saw that I saw blade one
it's a movie by the way
probably watched it again not too long
ago probably in the last six months I
can't remember when I watched one and
two in the last six months yeah movie
Blade one's unbelievable his mum's his
who's his mum again oh my God his mom is
a buddy no no no his mom is um I can't
remember her name his mom is an absolute
Dime Piece Sanaa Lathan that's it yeah
wow a woman loving basketball what a
woman yeah blade was good
most underrated action from all time bro
yeah I forgot about that where's his
slice when with that sword yeah in that
first scene when they go into the club
and it's Raining Blood bro he's dropping
bodies in that club I forgot about that
yeah one brought people to sleep in on
it yeah I'm hoping
um what's his name mashallah
I'm hoping when they when he um comes up
and does blade it's he's gonna try and
do it justice but he's not gonna touch
Wesley yeah it's gonna be next year I
think it's meant to drop 20 24 20 25.
hopefully hopefully what another side
track we're falling straight off this
energy question but I don't care it goes
do you know what do you know what
they're doing who's they Marvel the man
Dem oh the Marvel just Amanda mcdoing
okay my brother sent me a screenshot
they're doing up
um a whole Avatar Resurgence Airbender
avatar oh okay I was thinking what do
you mean Netflix are dropping two live
actions okay Avatar one Avatar Two
and then in 2020 live action live action
director by Hoover I don't know if it's
if it's not watch it I'm burning
watching it if they let M Night put his
hands on that Masterpiece one more time
so I'm saying I'm not watching if it's
him burning the whole thing down okay so
they've got two live actions okay and
then they've got in 2025 a uh season
three
season three
earthbender Avatar okay yeah and then
they've also dropped in a side season of
um
Zuko's got his own side season but
before that they're doing um
they're doing a sequel to like team
Avatar okay but before uh and dies and
stuff okay adult team Avatar okay what
they were doing but when they were
making what was that city called
bossing say no no no no no no the city
that um in the future in uh I don't
remember when uh ah it's called like
Central City or something like that
maybe I can't remember but um they make
uh obviously because Ang team Avatar
created that whole new world where um
the time frame that core is in yeah that
City that she lives in yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um obviously Ang and dim man built that
yeah but we and then you've got tarf
runs the police yes and Zuko was like
the general uh he's a fire lord so we're
doing like doing up team Avatar in the
future before all this stuff is built
okay and how they built all that stuff
and how she drops okay when is this
dropping that's dropping I want to say
2026 or something like that let me
quickly check summer 2023 Avatar live
action book one water summer
2025 that's too much of a gap but if
you're going to do it do it right yeah
live action book two Earth hmm then
we've got adult team Avatar October 10th
2025. this could be made up by the way
because now they're saying specific
October 10.
two and a half years from now between
October 10th anyway adult team Avatar
made up I could be chatting staff right
now then 2025 in the winter
um the new Earth avatar animated series
then we've got a Zuko animated film gang
then we've got
um that's 2026 then we've got a spin-off
series that they haven't said and then
we've got the live action Netflix uh
book three fire in 2027 and then
apparently in 2027 we've got an animated
film and another animated series as I'm
reading this I'm not gonna lie to you
guys I could have made this awesome
it's sounding incredibly far-fetched but
it sounds juicy if it's all real yeah
the fact that it's splitting up the
different elements as well um Avatar
water air so it's from a site called
Avatar news Okay
um wow okay cool hopefully it's all true
but if it's fake I've wasted four and a
half minutes of everyone's time yeah but
if if it's true I'm not sure when I
can't touch it uh he's not allowed you
can't touch anything afterwards yeah
yeah kind of he's doing Justice of the
new series I've heard episode one to
seven is boring episode one was boring
yeah episode one was born and I start
after I watched episode one I didn't go
back to it
so I mean bro I've heard episode one
through seven is irrelevant oh eight
nine ten is juice so I've heard
us so anyway it's a quick watch though
so I might I might just put it up and
see but anyway back to it well we
literally only just got got through one
what's something that's happened that's
made you think this can't be real life
getting down to business with a guy he
told me to call out his name we had the
same name
like a Charlie or something yeah or
Jordan Jordan bro it's so funny I went
to school with a u i this is when I
thought this isn't real life I went to
primary school with a black guy called
Jordan Mitchell okay and then went to
Secondary School in Northampton that was
in Luton went to Secondary School in
Northampton with a white girl called
Jordan Mitchell yeah that's when I was
like this is in real life yeah yeah
there aren't that many names
it's true Michelle tingers they're
running out of names bro
all right my baby daddy getting married
on my birthday
that that actually can't be real life
that card in real life that's a yeah
that can't be real life
your own neck bro getting married on my
birthday
also
because it's mad cause you can't
confront him of course not because he's
like Get over yourself fast it's nothing
to do with you I'm literally trying to
move on and you're here causing drama oh
yeah I intentionally designed my whole
wedding despite you
yeah obviously not
obviously not have him ready by itself
I've won the tax iron those jokes oh my
first wet dream
this can't be real this can't be real I
had my first one late in life say late I
was like
I think I'd already banged by the time I
had my first wet dream I think we've had
this discussion really I think so yeah
I'm pretty sure I'd already banned by
the time
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
woke up
rattled our bear bro rattled yeah yeah I
think yeah I I'd already banged by the
time I'd
um had my first wet dream and then I
think I had one or two okay as like I'm
talking like 17 years old okay and then
I think because I think once I bind was
that bag late in life again I banged it
like late 16 early 17. I can't remember
okay
um which I don't want to call that later
life but for me in that time yeah
give me something I I lost my virginity
I think I was 18. I kept on tossing it
was I 17 was I 18 but I remember it was
um the tail end of my final year so what
I would have been
um would have been 18.
that's in these in these dog days
it was late and it was like yeah my
savings sorry to cut you off my Saving
Grace was obviously I went to board of
school so it was a bit secluded and we
were I was one of like a handful of
black people in the school anyway oh
okay so it did it wasn't handed to you
yeah it wasn't handed to me and it also
there wasn't that much peer pressure
because I was it wasn't London or I
wasn't like in that I was off ends bro
oh fans so right the pressure I remember
my boy was telling me that he was eating
Tom like if I'm I hadn't touched
something I had only I'd only stinky
pinked oh my and then he was he got with
this girl yeah
still over till now
fam this is when we were like 16 no
comments if I'm still over till now
um Fair the fairest of places
um and yeah he got with her and then boy
I remember I I was guessed that I got a
couple fingers yeah patterned up yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then man said bro it
poem last night and I was like what did
you say fan what did you say I was
thinking get your bow cat lips away from
me
oh but also tell me everything I've not
heard that word in years Sam and I
remember I was gasp I couldn't Express
the gas yeah effects because you
couldn't be Associated I was like how
did this even come up oh yeah she said
she just said she wanted it and I was
like I remember thinking oh
the way I was jumped out yeah the way I
was horny bro yeah I was thinking yeah
good to ask me to do anything yeah and
I'll do it yeah facts yeah flipping out
and I remember thinking
bro so yeah I remember when I finally
yeah when I finally got it in there
quick
the quickest but I went around to like
30 seconds later oh Jesus
ready you're listening to me I was
already bro literally bang night
is that [__]
wow wow wow then literally 30 seconds
later I was in there again oh man
the next day found we was we was banging
like four times a day every day yeah and
you're not listening to me
you're not listening to me I couldn't
breathe without Palm when I was 17 bro I
was lost four times a day every day
every day bro bro yeah no matter what
she could have swine flu I'm up in there
I'm up in there that must have been sore
I was I didn't care yeah I know I didn't
care the soreness was just more yeah it
was just more Scentsy
disorders just meant more Scentsy
[Music]
oh my God fair play
well something has happened that's made
you think this can't be real life
I threw up on a stranger in the middle
of a flight oh my God
a homeless man chased me down the street
with his tall out I'm yet to recover
that's something that I promise you is
not real life a homeless man just peace
out I I don't think you are how
petrified I would be if I saw that
petrified I can't even just ream to the
top of my life I can't even speak on it
a soft tool just flapping and he's dying
at your footpel
I was scream at the top of my lungs down
I I would really really struggle to like
unfreeze myself
I would be [__] terrified for that
you don't understand yeah oh I
understand perfectly
you stand perfectly
imagine yes
oh my God it's scary because it's giving
you something he's he's intentionally
trying to give you something
that's scary
when the girl I was seeing facetimed me
and she was with my wife
the girl I was seeing facetimed me and
she was with my wife
this can't be real life bro
that is also stuff that will
like I'm sure everyone's felt it but
like
your veins become ice yeah
you feel everything wrong cold
and the frog in your throat is large
she's like talk then you're swallowing
you can't speak bro
nah nah whatever you literally can't
because speed are you just there like
what are you doing and hang up I've got
time for these games bro my my side
piece could never FaceTime me and my
wife be next to her and they think
they're catching me out hung up you're
not you're not because I'm hanging up
you've wasted a whole afternoon
I'm not entertaining it and I'm not
going back to any of your yards any of
your yards wherever I'm at right now
this is what I'm staying fast with the
clothes on my back and my keys in my
pocket that's all I've got that's all
I've got left I'm not entertaining on
any of this I'm not entertaining a
single slice of it because where does it
go from here I've lost you both so why
would I put myself through this what are
you guys actually benefiting from this
why are you guys together fam they love
but the thing is as well
when they're willing to go to that
length yeah you can pattern one of them
back
you compare one of them's weaker than
the other
[Music]
[Applause]
one of them is definitely weaker than
the other
the other facts you have to get in there
and turn around
whoever whoever didn't make the car why
for side one of these are weak or
whatever he was getting this next week
facts
I mean I agree bro
[Music]
fast
those jokes
oh this made me so hot one of those
weaker than you
well yeah if they go into those links
one of them if not both wants you back
they just want you to be punished facts
that's what I said when it was weak on
all right back to it
what's something that's made that's
happened that's made you think this
can't be real life
this guy fingered the girl on the bus
then called his girlfriend once she got
off
he's a Playboy
um if I was there I'd be shocked
disgusting but also teach me mentor
ing me under your wings because you did
this so blase on the bus who is she
[__] I need to know the whole the whole
story bro the whole story bro I remember
Mentor me
I remember this is so stupid bro do you
remember did you just want to save by
the Bell of course
Arab I remember Saved by the Bell one of
the early episodes is where
um
I can't remember his name in there Mario
Lopez whoever Mario Lopez played in
Saved by the Bell on his first date
because I remember
what's the main Don's name all I
remember is Screech yeah yeah there's
maybe George there's Kelly Zach I think
is the main guy AC Slayer is Mario
Kelly AC Slater yeah Zach Zach right so
Zach used to run things like say he's TJ
from Recess Zach had things patent in
high school
when Mario Lopez rocked up on day one
here [__] they're [__] yeah they
ain't seen skin like that and he was
wearing like a singlet he was wrestling
he was patting a man up and he had
things on sale and I remember watching
that as like a five-year-old yeah
thinking that's the dream Mario Lopez
with his Jericho is just doing stuff
doing stuff bro that's the dream that's
he's literally living the dream when did
this come out 1989 wow two years before
I was born wow yeah these men have been
acting yeah bro screechers started doing
doing a PornHub in it
excuse me did you not hear about that
maybe I did actually wait wait maybe I
actually did yeah got balls deep in Porn
Bro
um why does that ring a bell
let me I actually have to look at that
and say that now give me a second
doing what Screech
I didn't see him do nothing I just heard
bro
yeah
uh he did die
yes Greece did die before he died he was
slanging
swear yeah he was slanging pipe on on
screen I'm sure he was screech's sex
tape 51 minute Dustin Diamond's best and
worst moments from Screech to jail Jesus
yeah
yeah he really did I feel like adult not
adults I feel like child actors tend to
like especially from back a day don't
they just
um That's So Raven the the breader in
that so raven I can't remember his name
who was talking to me about this the
other day Sam the barber was talking
about homeboy to me the other day yeah
he's saying he went through stuff he
went through I remember him being on
socials all day every day for like the
past months or so this is four years ago
five years ago I can't remember saying
he's like Kanye's baby or something I
don't remember that I just know he was
on drugs
I just know he was on drugs but he was
on staff that's all I'm remembering yeah
he was on style and then we had
um is it Josh from Drake and Josh yeah
he went through some stuff yeah he
slammed out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
had that meth diet yeah
he was on that meth diet
um I think he and nickel had a little
situation as well reprized themselves
again yeah a lot of a lot of childhood
actors mum they they go it's a tough old
gig all that Fame bro get to you
Olsen twins fun fact brother the Olsen
twins were my first like Crush
Uber Crush yeah like I was just too
young to fap yeah but if I was a tiny
bit older but don't listen to me
you man yeah I had a book of Guinness
book I had the Guinness Book of Records
I can't remember what year it was back a
day and there was a page on there with
the Olsen twins
yeah and my brain was doing this yeah
wow this is the first time I thought
about this in like 20 years wow my brain
was doing stuff bro and I was just just
getting to that point yeah where I'm
like a year or two away from fapping out
yeah yeah yeah yeah couldn't understand
the feelings I was having in my body you
know what to do with that picture yeah
do
do every day I was staring at that
picture listen to me every day I would
stare at that picture bro wow Olsen
twins wow that's sending me back what a
throwback that is a throwback Jesus bro
yeah two years later their Pages would
have been stuck together
anyway who do you think I'll go back to
this who do you think has more notoriety
um the Olsen twins or Elizabeth Olsen
who the hell Elizabeth Olsen is um
Marvel she is
um Captain Marvel she's there she's
their sister or cousin she's that
she's a sister yeah she's an awesome
twin sister yeah
what do you mean Captain Marvel you know
Captain Marvel the actress Brie Larson
who's a little no Elizabeth Olsen is um
Scarlet Witch is it Scarlet Witch
Scarlet Witch sorry sorry Scarlet Witch
my bad my bad Scarlet Witch Scarlet
Witch
the only reason why I knew is because
after I had watched
um One Division I realized her name was
something Olson I clicked on it and then
to be fair I forgot the Olsen twins
existed yeah what were they even in what
was that show called
I can't remember like a Disney Channel I
got a Disney show they were in bag of
movies obviously Parent Trap all of them
things there as well like back a day
they were so I'm saying they had their
notoriety they did in their day but
obviously homegirl I guess not for her
name in that family but obviously
Scarlet Witch is stupid famous so yeah
she's she's got more notoriety hands
down but as just a name of the Olsen
name yeah yeah say less I will just
write it back I've got quite a few more
actually what's something that's
happened that's made you think this
can't be real life
gave money to a homeless man and he
threw it back in my face saying shake
that ass
[Laughter]
shake it bang man just
Shake That Shake it I need memories I
don't need money facts what's your 11
pounds get back take some
hilarious crazy bro
my dad caught me beating my meat in the
shower I was reaching climax and
couldn't stop no no
[Laughter]
but that's impossible
yeah yeah you have to you have I will
close my fist over my peace bro
nothing's flying out there's I've beat
my meat and child one time is the worst
experience of my life I don't know how
man can do that in the shop one time
yeah yeah you've done it multiple times
yeah
wet and wild in the shower yeah it's not
the right kind of whip bro yeah the
place it's like nah it's not it it's not
it's not it's not it's not no it's it's
not bad what are you saying remember I'm
saying nah
it's not it bro
damn it's that gritty gritty that's why
I don't do like bang in the shower
either bagging the shells long
bang showers long but obviously it
depends on the shower but it's still
long at the same time bro it's like your
tool is ribbed
I hear you
um my dad getting arrested two days
after saying he'd change
tall men
I said I'm done with this
best of the art again again they said
he'd change two days Oh my days bro
right sorry
yeah do you know what show sends you
life lessons bro it's just a bit too
serious okay Peppa Pig bro
[Music]
he said they were gun fingers bro Peppa
Pig Peppa Pig bro Peppa Pig
breathless and there's certain things in
Peppa Pig where you're like raw
what is going on there's a bro I can't
remember oh the names but it's like
someone's
someone's dad is not on it bro
on this family stuff is not on it okay
and basically
he's a sailor yeah yeah he's a sailor
and he loves sailing bro he loves
sailing the Seven Seas prop and he comes
home one day and he's like bro I'm I've
done I've talked it yeah that that like
saying is done I'm here to be your dad
and home boys like gang gang gang Dad
yeah yeah yeah yeah anytime he gets a
bit excited yeah there's one time
someone's I think like Grandpa pigs boat
crashes or something like that and he
needs something to rescue him so he pops
over
and then he's like I'm leaving
I'm trying to sell the seven seas and he
said dad you said you were done and he's
like bruh I'm a sailor I'm a sailor shop
I can't deal with this that [__] I'm
saying in a way I'm a man of the Seas
bro stop trying to hold me back let me
leave my Peppa Pig I don't think you can
bro certain gems and Peppa Pig
shut down thing
you come up with someone who wonders
James hilarious
wow Peppa Pig wow I was not expecting
that I've ever come out your mouth ever
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna reel through the last few
yeah or something that's happened that's
made you think
um this can't be real life
in secondary school some boy just
randomly grabbed my teacher's neck
no that's impossible
random randomly grabbed my teacher's
neck found we said this before in the
patreon episode teaching Khan yeah
continue this way
they get it physical assault they get it
bro I used to walk around thinking I
reckon I could yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no obviously not a female one yeah
yeah but like the guy ones that used to
just throw their weight around
history teachers like head of year yeah
yeah catch me outside
um I'll rock you bro don't don't tell me
I'm laughing too loud
yeah obviously you would have tummed me
up now that I'm a grown man I see what a
year eight looks like wow I've reckon I
could knock out a hundred of them
they can't do nothing
I don't think I was looking at big big
Mr body yeah and thinking I'll Tamp your
head off oh yeah don't chat to me it's
all imagination though he would have
grabbed me like that and just launched
me your feet would have dangled in
school the facts bro fact I think that's
probably I think there probably needs to
be a time in your life when you're an
adolescent child yeah when you're you're
hitting puberty and you're starting to
feel like you're strong yeah and you're
getting aggressive yeah there should be
like a screening process where you have
a grown-ass Man circle you like put
pause on you not like not like yeah yeah
yeah fist but just grip grab you and
make you feel completely vulnerable
completely helpless any scenario yeah
but you're thinking I can take him if
this happens yeah yeah let yourself get
at us on our own and watch what he does
to you yeah and then you think okay
enough jokes
oh a guy was clearing his throat and
accidentally spat on my hand i'm start I
started crying and asking why
he was like why
just Spang
she's like why why why why crying just
asking why clear my what do you mean why
bro why me I'd apologize and then the Y
would spin me yeah yeah I'm sorry sorry
why why would you do that why why I
couldn't breathe
I couldn't [__] breathe bro you
should even walk off I'm so sorry
I said so what would you want
my bank account hitting negative three
times in one week
uni boy
uni boy yeah
one week I used to get this Barclays
text
every other overdraft HSBC text oh my
God they wouldn't they wouldn't even
give me like 24 hours as soon as I've
gone over it five minutes a day I'm
getting that text oh facts bro you need
to put this much in if before 11 59 for
11 59 or it's eight pound on top
tomorrow
fam I remember and it's because I
couldn't keep up on my direct debits
yeah I'd wake up to a text in the
morning just about why is it happening
because you've planned the last 40
pounds you've got you've planned it bro
I'm not eating lunch today facts that's
what they're telling me that's what the
text is telling me I'm not eating lunch
today
bursary at all they didn't give anything
yeah that's crazy Jesus meeting my dad
in London for the first time and him
telling me he paid my mother to abort me
so who got did she keep the money
back I don't even think of that yeah
where's the money where's the money how
much did you pay
from the dollar I'd be like you owe me
money to my daughter
you literally only P I have a you what
your mama give us
here you are you owe me money and you're
asking me for more money every month
just know
crazy
oh wow he invited me to watch him and
his friends play Dungeons and Dragons
see that's that's out of there I can't
be realized that's really really out
there it's a big bang theory you need to
be a confident brother to be inviting a
thing to watch you play Dungeons and
Dragons or you just read books and roll
dice fam and just make up something
yeah yeah they're mine wonders
roll the seven and then the [__]
foreign
for you roll a seven what piece of armor
would you use I'm literally five days
and last but not least what's something
that's happened that's made you think
this can't be real life
when I saw my first
uncircumcised black penis
swear
what do you mean this can't be real life
wow
the thing is I don't know how girls
because I've never seen a crazy pump
in real life bro watching embarrassing
bodies and them things oh yeah yeah I've
seen some like stuff that I was like oh
so I've never seen a poem like in real
life and be like Jesus yeah
it's like it's an Audi like I've never
seen like an Audi
you know what I mean
I've never seen that out
nah you're Wicked bro bro I heard girls
call them always I've never called yeah
I've heard it I heard it bro some girls
call them out ease I've never seen an
eyebrow okay so like but women every
single time they see a tour they don't
know what to expect yeah facts yeah yeah
every single time is before women have
seen [__] oh bro they've seen it
imagine every single girl you meet you
don't know what's gonna happen under
there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
too stressful that doesn't even it
doesn't even enter my it doesn't cross
my mind it doesn't enter my head yeah
[Music]
no wonder they don't want to keep adding
bodies bro true it's just too much
stress true true
anyway welcome to the show guys welcome
to the show guys welcome back happy
Monday as always
um it's a beautiful day here in London
England and uh yeah man we're we're
happy to have you here [__] The Vibes
are vibing always and yeah man guys if
you are enjoying the show so far please
please please head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
yes sir please give us a very very
unnoticeable for you three pound a month
Tempe a day run the pizza SMG and then
digest three plus years three and a half
years now of uh bonus content uh stuff
that uh yeah we wouldn't get away with
saying now stuff that was just pointless
and stupid and fun when a Time
yeah man where two young men had a dream
and chased it [__] and here we are now
yeah mum
um wasn't all across cracked out to be
um but anyway guys patreon.com three
Panama of Tempe a day run the p and uh
join our Discord Channel join all the
other cult babies and uh obviously binge
all the content you can possibly manage
on top of that guys if you are watching
us on YouTube please subscribe to the
channel
leave a nice like turn the notifications
on chaps a thing in the comments if you
please and uh finally guys if you're
listening please please it means the
world to us if you could follow the page
that you're listening on and uh leave a
nice review five stars is obviously
preferable
whatever you say say it with your chest
facts
along that note
Fire Lord Flags it's got some trash news
to tell us today something that we
didn't think we needed to hear but
probably do no pressure
what have you got you might have seen
this man charged after calling his
ex-girlfriend over 800 times in two days
I've not seen that
a Maryland man is facing years behind
bars after he was charged with cyber
stalking his ex-girlfriend including
bombarding her with over 800 phone calls
in two days
uh Derek Bower's 44 was charged on
Monday with one count of cyber stalking
for allegedly harassing his former
partner through text messages phone
calls and via Facebook
um the U.S attorney said in 20 in
December 2022 I was called his ex who
lives in Morgan County 815 times in over
two days in over a two-day period he
also reported he also reportedly sent
her thousands of text messages over
several months and used social media
posts to embarrass her and interfere
with her livelihood if convicted bowels
would face up to five years in prison
first of all
props
800 times over one weekend was it over
two days bro
[Music]
I mean I don't think I've got an energy
to keep doing that
that's 400 times a day block five yeah
to be fair how is she not blocked him
block how is she not blocked him that's
true why why should babies come through
literally getting to the police like
just block it block him and then report
him yeah block him obviously leave your
yard yeah
as soon as he goes straight to voicemail
he's got your door peel into your yard
it's scary hours it's scary yeah
yeah as soon as you press broke pack
your [__] go dip yeah he knows where you
live yeah yeah yeah yeah no but yeah bro
um think about that
wow
he's scary bro trust me
um yeah I can't fathom stuff like that
800 calls in two days
that's the kind of stuff where like she
must have said we need to talk or
something but not now
Monday yeah I'm bailing you a thousand
times yeah yeah a thousand times I'm
sending you all the abuse on text tell
me now tell me everything I need to know
because I can't wait 24 hours or 48. I
can't tell me what I did don't you know
what I didn't tell me how to make it up
to you because I've got no more answers
I just need you back in my life
yeah um but yeah I was gonna say with
the props thing is props um props that
he could be going to pen for this
because bro like
outside of like spousal and like
uh relationship like kind of like abuse
stalkerish kind of stuff like stuff
that's like the social media based stuff
bro like
social media is actually nuts like
social media is actually nuts and like
the her the amount of harassment that
goes unpunished yeah on like IG and
stuff like that yeah it's just stuff
that
we're not used to like dealing with like
if if your neighbor was harassing you on
a daily basis
something's gonna happen yeah hopefully
something's gonna happen yeah yeah but
when you're getting random DMS from
strange bastards yeah
who have like fake accounts just saying
[__] there's nothing you can do unless
you're gonna take it take it there and
like the bigger for the following you
can't even conclude that it's one person
it's just just bear abuse box
um so yeah that obviously he's taking it
to a different level yeah but uh like to
start introducing just like severe
replunishment yeah for like because bro
I like I've seen heinous messages before
directed at me have directed at other
people where I'm just like wow yeah
wow it's long bro you need to go pen for
that kind of stuff some certain man just
don't know how to act when it comes to
talking behind a keyboard they really
don't attack but yeah I'm happy like you
said it's good that there's some severe
punishment for stuff like that because
it's not on man yeah but she she needs
to block homeboy and move to her sisters
ASAP yeah yeah because he he will find
you also like this is mad as well like
how because this happened to me it's
happened to you it happens to everyone
how do you find yourself this is in
terms of literally what you just said
like this isn't real life how do you
find yourself in a relationship with
someone
who is this level of person fam and it's
only when his push came to shove yeah
the the true colors will come out 800.
I can't count to 800. oh neither I'll be
so bored yeah if I was counting as fast
as I could and like tolerate as long as
I could I wouldn't make it 800. I
wouldn't make it to 100. yeah
I promise you I'm gonna make it 100. bro
it's long bro no it's long I just don't
oh man yeah it's crazy it's crazy I'm
I'm hoping it does go to jail for five
years or whatever because that's that's
ridiculous if I pick if I dialed the
same number 800 times
I need ee to balance wait what are you
doing yeah yeah you're right yeah sauce
is your phone broke fax what's going on
yeah yeah I'll need the network provider
to do something they would have to cut
me off yeah the network provider will
have to look up you need to text me and
say this is for your own good this is
your last diet yeah use it wisely
save it
you're taking a piss leave the poor girl
alone
because
I'm deep to number five is she's on ee2
I did my due diligence leave her alone
this is your last dial
I promise you
wow we'll block you internally bro oh
your contract's done bro crazy bro right
now that's funny Right Moving On Moving
On I have some juicy Married at First
Time oh yeah completely forgot yeah yeah
I'm a bit more up to date so based on
what REM was telling me the other day
I've seen the whole thing okay and you
know what's mad bro I'm on episode
um fam you're banned from drinking out
of them you're banned from drinking out
there with a microphone that close to
you that's a sin
your band bro
I don't know what rem's going through
with those on yeah their headphones are
we couldn't have headphones I would
smack something
I'm not even deep and how close the
tickets
[__] yeah not bad bro that's hilarious
um
what's mad is right I need to get the
cast up again we've had in the lot I've
only watched three episodes since the
last time yeah we've had developments
Daddy okay we've had developments have
you got are you up to the are you up to
a part where there's that new chick that
we've not seen so that's not in this
next episode I see her okay Jesus she's
fine okay Jesus wept she's fine
good Lord she's the most buying one out
of all of these like Les good Lord she's
fine I don't know Evelyn Evelyn Christ
say that yeah there's two more couples
coming in
the other one I don't know nothing about
you looks boring
oh say last okay okay okay okay okay
okay
a monster right so let's get into the
sauce let's spill some tea yeah right so
so in the next episode for the preview
we finally see I finally catch up to
Claire Ted and Jesse that she's a cheat
yes that she lips Adam yes do you know
how many episodes it's been since she
actually did it to now I think the
episode where she tells him is like
episode 13 or 14. okay she did the lips
in like episode three or four
oh raw they've stretches that look fam
her and Jesse like this right now
and every time someone else is acting up
cheating doing something she's the first
one to run up oh she's the first one to
run her mouth I can't believe it no I
hate things like that so next episode we
see that and I'm I'm excited to see
where that spiral's off to okay I don't
know how REM is is is here at work
um but to be fair I think where he's at
is like family week maybe family week's
the most boring week bro okay
there's not enough juice bro okay but
anyway let me get into it
who shall I start with
um
I'm gonna start with
us
ually let's start with
let me drink my band drink yeah yeah I'm
gonna start soft and we're gonna hop
skip and jump to ferocity okay right I'm
gonna start soft with
okay I'm gonna go back to our power no
like our favorite stupid couple yeah
Bronte and Harrison right okay
so we've got a little four-way power
struggle right now a little drama with
Bronte Harrison yeah
Along with Dan and Sandy Sandy okay
Bronte Harrison Dan and Sandy right okay
so Dan and Harrison went on a night out
so I told you before Harrison is a he's
a kleptomaniac bro
he is the biggest liar and the worst
liar okay he has satin that's not
clicking in is he the one that
um he's the one has a thing on the
outside that helps him oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so him and Bronte Bronte
has accepted hell and just been like
I haven't got the strength to cry
anymore
this is the man they've given me so I
must deal with it I'm gonna deal with it
oh
so it's like me feeding you broccoli
every day and for the first eight days
you're fighting me yes give me broccoli
one more time we're gonna stab you yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then you're at your
Wit's End and then you come in another
day and you just eat it yeah yeah you
just do as you told and you eat it and
your soul is dead that's brought to you
right now her soul is gone
and she's just eating the broccoli damn
okay yeah yeah so and Harrison is
twisting the knife
okay
it's like me feeding you this broccoli
and then you finally accept the broccoli
and then instead of me saying I'm so
happy you're eating the broccoli and I'm
sorry that I'm making you eat it it's me
saying like
I'm so happy you've fixed what's wrong
in your head because you needed this bro
yeah
this is the best thing for you
I'm trying to facility because I'm doing
you a favor okay facilitating the
broccoli yeah and you've been moving mad
yeah yeah so not even I'm not even going
to say Well done I'm saying about time
how is insane about time yes I've been
here yeah I've been here okay about time
you sorted yourself out it's crazy zero
accountability okay anyway okay check
this out so Dan and Harrison going a
night out right yes for some reason I've
never seen them speak before okay but
they're on a Saturday night out they go
to a bar
while they're at the bar
um basically something happens and I'll
rule back to it so here's the story The
Way We Get It
here's a story the way we get it all we
know is them two went to a bar yeah and
on after Harrison gives Adam a call just
on a bro chat okay yeah yeah Adam
because
he he doesn't know bro code whatsoever
has Harrison on loudspeaker
Adams misses is Janelle
and he's he's got Harris on the phone
just letting him chat doesn't tell him
he's on loudspeaker just letting him
chat yeah
fam bio yeah bio so anyway
Harrison is telling them oh me down went
to the bar couple things trying to
chirps us
message gets mixed up a little bit and
Janelle hears Dan got a girl's number
I apparently my dad's like 40. calm oh
46. he's a mature guy never given anyone
any reason to think he's that kind of
guy okay so who's that move again sorry
Sandy okay okay Sandy's never been in a
relationship I'm feeling so she's a
virgin
um oh so yeah this is a big one for her
so anyway
we get to the the dinner group dinner
Janelle Adams misses who overheard the
call with Harrison pulls one of her
girls aside and says I got some juicy
info fam I've got some tea and I want to
scratch it in someone's face
yeah I need advice yeah yeah do I do it
or don't I yeah and she said to Adam
what do I do what do I do Adam's like do
your thing Adam should have been keep
your mouth shut because you've got the
wrong information first and foremost
first and foremost
yeah facts he was like whatever you want
to do just do it
I can't tell you what to do but whatever
you want to do just do it keep my name
out of it so they they get whole group
together not that that's not there yeah
they've got a whole group together and
they're all like what should we do what
should we do we should do Harrison
stumbles in
no no no no Harrison's talking to Adam
and saying like waguan and Adam's like
ah obviously Janelle heard about what
happened when you're on the phone to me
the other day she wants to know if she
should bring it up Harrison turns out is
the one Dan didn't get anyone's number
it was Harrison
but what Harrison's saying is is we went
out and Ting tried to chirps me ask me
for her number I said you're not having
my number yeah I'll take your number
took the number and then deleted it okay
because he just didn't want to deal with
the guy yeah yeah that's what he's
saying yeah and Dan was there yeah and
he taught Dan yeah
um
so
he goes out there and they're like oh
Harrison um yeah we're just deciding oh
what to do about this number thing and
he's like bright red like right because
he doesn't know that Janelle thinks it
was Dan he thinks that everyone knows
it's him yeah and he's like what do you
think you'll do yeah yeah yeah yeah what
is this yeah don't speak to me so
casually yeah
you're attacking me and then um one of
the girls is like oh I didn't even know
you were involved yeah and he's like
what's going on he's confused he says
why they're like yeah we're just
figuring out how we tell Sandy um about
what Dan did Matt says
I know like yeah like he got the girl's
number and he said like you literally
like see him like
that and he says personally I think you
should shut the [__] up
it's not your business shut your mouth
bro I'm scared yeah and then they were
like no no well I don't know if we
should speak to Dan I don't think it's
Andy and he says well I was there do you
want me to speak to Dad and then they're
like yeah that's perfect you speak to
that see he said let me get this
straight yeah if I speak to Dan he
literally if I speak to Dan this all
goes away yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it all goes away
he's like he pulls down to the side
gas lies down and says so do you
remember when we went out the other
night and we both got those girls
numbers and deleted them yeah it does
this one I don't get anyone's number bro
he's like yeah yeah obviously we both
got the numbers yeah yeah these might
think it was just you
I told them yeah but they're not
listening
I told them you didn't do anything wrong
be with me
that's like what's going to save himself
what's going on bro so they all get back
in there Sandy his misses Dan's misses
finders out and she's heated she's like
so walk one you got girls number he's
like I didn't get anyone's numbers he's
like well obviously people are saying
you've got a girl's number he's like
brother I didn't get nothing I'd screams
all his accusations so anyway yeah
after the precious house arrived
Harrison realizes I can't get away with
this yeah so he pulls his message to
aside says look this is what happened me
and Dan went out obviously you know that
I haven't told you because I didn't
think it was relevant but these men so I
need to tell you now
gold trips me ask my number I said
you're not having my number I'll take
your number she put my her number on my
phone I deleted it straight away
his wife broccoli yeah is like calm calm
nothing wrong with that everyone else
kicking up a fuss bro kicking up a fuss
making Harrison feel like [__] yeah and
I don't check for Harrison yeah but I'm
gonna hold my hands up I'm gonna get
smoke for this yeah I'm gonna hold my
hands up
I'm I'm kind of as long as he's telling
the truth yeah I'm kind of with him on
this yeah so basically because the
narrative that they're trying to say is
that you're [__] in the wrong the
experts told him this as well you're
[__] in the wrong bro for getting a
girl's number yeah
you're in the room for Governor's Rumba
you should have literally
said to the girl I'm married and the
thing's done yeah I know from personal
experience telling a girl who's moving
to you drunk in a bar saying I'm married
or I've got a girl or whatever it's not
necessarily the last straw for anything
yeah yeah it makes them want you more so
he told her he told everyone I got the
number because I couldn't be bothered
for this conversation and I deleted it
but he's not articulate enough to
actually say
me because they kept saying you'll get
you've got a girl's number you goes
number you've got a girl's number
the way he should have said it is if I
got a number and deleted it after did I
get a number yeah no I didn't I don't
have the number so I didn't get a number
it's like saying if I give you a pound
and take it straight back and say you
got a pound no I didn't get a pound I
caught one
number yeah yeah I didn't got nothing
yeah yeah yeah so but he's he's
genuinely not articulate enough to say
stuff he just when he gets the pressure
he shuts down he gets angry and he shuts
down bro so people were gunning for him
and I've been gunning for him after
every single thing he's done
this one as long as he's telling the
truth I'm actually kind of on this side
because sometimes he said I couldn't be
bothered to shut the girl down yeah
because I know for a fact as well
sometimes a girl will come up to you and
be like you're paying run me your number
if you say to the girl
I've got a girlfriend
if she's drunk enough she could easily
turn around and like where is she then
is she here yeah what you can't have
friends like all these typical bars bro
yeah and everyone in this show is making
out like these conversations don't exist
and as soon as you point your ring is
wrapped that's not the it's not real
life and the thing is girls are saying
it like say guys guys never take that as
an answer this wedding ring thing yeah
no guy takes that as an answer yeah
he'll say where's your man now the facts
why are you here a lot yeah yeah he's
protecting who's protecting I'll never
let you come here alone that's how dick
has chat bro I've seen them do it
so for them to to play so coy to say
that all you had to say was married and
it's done and the fact that you went
above and beyond to get a girl's number
means you're intended to do something
with that they send you in above and
beyond to get her number which means
you're intended to do something and he's
like brother no I'm not no I'm not bro I
just didn't want this smoke I wanted to
leave me alone I thought this is the
easiest way and his wife is like I'm
with you yeah I know what it's like yeah
Bronte is the only one in the situation
who's like I'm on your side bro if I was
in my man's shoes and my wife or Bronte
for example was on my side I don't need
to listen to the rest of you I don't
need to listen to them literally that's
what he should have said as well in that
room he should have been like
this is me and her yeah if I'm telling
her this is what I did and she's telling
me I've been there I understand yeah
only you can shut up I'm Claire was in
there like it leaves a bad taste in my
mouth
Adam's dick was in your mouth chat about
bad taste damn
your mouth the Stars yeah
and everyone's like no no no no no no no
no no no he should have been like I
don't need to hear anything from you I
don't care what she thinks yeah so
you're just giving her bad vibes yeah or
you might have just giving her wrong
information when all you men are up to
stuff anyway so that was so now Dan's
not checking for Harrison okay because
Harrison threw him under the bus yeah
through him under the peak he could have
and the thing is with him he could have
sorted the whole thing out when they
originally confronted him and said and
he realized oh they think it's down not
me he could have easily just been like
no no no no it wasn't done it was me
even if he didn't want to throw him
completely he would have been like I was
there too yeah it was both of us he
didn't get a girl's number
go we just wanted to get rid of the
girls and we get another phone together
now and we both deleted it he could have
included himself in it yeah
and threw down under the bus and thought
he could take down a side and be like
you're under Fire yeah you're on the
fire agree with us we're going to get
you out of this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so anyway that was the juice of that one
brought down I'm listening
then I'm gonna move on
to Josh and Melissa okay so this is what
REM supposed the other day okay oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this one
actually saying you're not [__] me
enough yeah okay okay okay okay okay he
said Josh was crying fam is exactly how
REM said
Josh was crying his eyes out oh no
no he looks like such a nice guy the
nicest guy
bro Melissa's horrible oh she's saying
you're not a man bro you're not a man so
just before they go to the commitments
area she's trying to suss where his
head's at okay so she's like do you want
to chat like it's been awkward the last
few days
he's saying nothing she's like where's
your head at how you feeling
I don't know and you can tell as soon as
he gets on that couch yeah he's gonna
he's spilled yeah everyone needs to say
yeah yeah yeah yeah so fam they get down
and he says you can speak first he says
that to her he says that to her speak to
their man first did they do it together
yeah together as they speak to them
first today what you want to say she's
saying
there's no intimacy there's this there's
that like we're just not there like
fam he comes out and starts saying stuff
we didn't even know was the case he
comes out and says the biggest issue in
this relationship is a matter of control
she tries to tell me how long am I
allowed on my phone how long am I
allowed to watch TV
when I'm allowed to go out who am I
allowed to be with fam how long am I I'm
allowed to read my books whoa 42 year
old man big man I'm talking about here
she's gonna control the whole thing he
said even when we had the discussion
about like all she cares about is sex
she thinks she can turn around and be
like we're not having sex anymore like I
never said I don't want to have sex
anymore well I said you just care about
too much everything is control control
control control and then like now she
wants to tell me I'm not a man I don't
know how to love I don't have to be
intimate she needs a man's man I'm not a
man's man bro as he's saying it he's
crying bro he's crying the experts are
basically like Melissa
[__] you
[__] you do you know what she said
to get herself out of this she plucked
the most out of context thing ever
imaginable and was like
first of all before that she was like I
don't know what to tell you I just I do
need a man like I need a real man I just
don't see him as a real man she kept
saying she didn't understand what she
was saying was wrong and literally all
the other contestants were like Korean
gym Bros oh so everyone else can hear
everyone's here
they were all in the same room just
hearing it oh that's awkward I was just
crying crying bro and he's trying to
hold it he's not even like yeah he's
sitting there his lips quivering like
that and there's one tear going like
that and he's trying to firm it and then
as he said all this all this all this
about this is how I feel this is what's
happening she's calling me this she's
calling me that calling me that and
they're like Melissa what do you have to
say for yourself like how do you feel
she's like you know what bro we banged
at the weekend and like it was just
nothing
it was literally just nothing like he
gave me nothing like it was so like
physical there's no there was nothing
there
and then from one of the experts was
like what's that God do with anything
about yeah he said why did you say that
yeah you can see what you're doing to
him yeah and he's saying how he feels
and you'll pickle up a random time yeah
just to Twist a knife in him look at him
look at him just looking at the floor
shaking shaking and crying no he says
[__] this Gob stood out all the man then
went out okay that's what you said yeah
yeah yeah chased him out just drag him
back in yeah yeah bro I was scratching
the TV
yeah this [__] right so if both of them
say leave yeah they leave yeah if both
of them say stay they stay if one says
leave once they stay the expert says
right you've got one more week if you
come back yeah if you come back here
even if once let's leave again and once
this day you're leaving you've got one
more week to fix this
he goes in there Josh says oh I'm
leaving leave straight she wrote leave
crossed it out wrote stay
and then the van experts like what are
you on bro you're a Blue Tick yeah yeah
you're moving mad you think you can
destroy my boy like this and say give me
him another week yeah nah I don't want
you enough I'm dipping said he's not
going back to you facts yeah I've never
done this before he's not going back
with you facts let him out facts [__]
Foster yeah I want Melissa to cry on her
own bro right on her Road doesn't start
rubbing his back and everything no don't
touch me I'm literally get your hands
off me get your hands off what kind of
woman is this she's the devil bro
she's the devil wow wow that brings me
on to the real devil of the show okay
this brings me on to the real devil in
the show Shannon Shannon Shannon Shannon
who's his who's his take Caitlyn Shannon
and Caitlin okay
let me drink oh yeah he's tapped okay so
last time we spoke about Shannon he was
saying I'm in love with my ex he was in
a field position outside on the phone
yeah yeah X
um and they said I love her I just love
her
and they're trying to figure it out so
he's basically gone to the experts and
said I want to stay I want to do better
[__] my ex I want to be here yeah I want
to be here with Caitlyn
so they have a couple days couple days
and they're doing these intimacy
exercises yep they have to stare at each
other for five minutes they have to kiss
they have to hug they have to do all
these intimate stuff right go on a date
and all this stuff
fam
my man stared at his team for five
minutes and then after Woods went back
to the cameraman was like I'm not on it
bro I know I said I wanna they want me
to try hard and I said I want to try
harder I just don't fancy this girl
like you can't force me to fancy her you
can force me to stay here you can force
me to be nice you can't force me to
fancy her that's true well technically
that's true yeah this brother took it
too far what do you do fam bearing in
mind yeah bearing in mind this whole
time he's crying over his accents like
she didn't raise her voice she didn't do
nothing to him
she was she was consoling him she's only
wanted to be there for him okay ever
she's never done a bad thing to her wife
she's a wife bro she's here console you
while you're crying over next things
yeah yeah bro a gem find another he
banged his ex a week before he got here
yeah yeah
bam he sat there and he goes they have
like a bit of an awkward conversation
and and she and he says she says how are
you feeling like I can tell the energy
is a bit she says that she says to him
like ever since we did the staring thing
earlier I can tell the energy is a bit
off like is there anything you want to
say man says
Prof you know what that actually is
um
I don't find you attractive in the
slightest word for word fam I must say
everything I say he says word for what I
don't find you attractive in the
slightest you're a good looking girl is
this one-on-one or is this okay no
there's a one-on-one in the apartment
it's them two and the camera cameras
yeah he said I I like I don't find you
attractive in the slightest it's like
you're a lovely looking girl but not to
my eyes
to my eyes you said stop playing your
lovely looking go just not to my eyes
and he said and you know what's actually
mad he said you know what's actually mad
bro like I came on here
hoping that like
I would be paired up with a banging
thing I came on here hoping that I'll be
paired up on a bang and saying like I
was standing in that aisle waiting to
turn around and I wanted to be wowed and
he said you know what if I would have
turned around he said I wanted to be
wowed and I saw you
and if if I were to turn around I've
been wild none of this x stuff would
have been happening I wouldn't be
thinking about my ex yeah I would have
deleted a number on the spot yeah but I
got you
and because I'm stuck with you I can't
help but think about my ex what is going
on live TV on live TV to our face
I was like you're just Butters bro nah
nah The Producers stepped in producers
sort of stepped in she was crying I
can't say stuff she was she couldn't
breathead she went outside and cried and
couldn't breathe I [__] bet fam I've
never seen a mess like it she couldn't
breathe I bet yeah bro she's like I'm
gonna be sick
it was wild shanna's not even the
handsome brother like he's nothing bro
so why is he moving he's 30 years old
looking 48. why is he moving yeah he
looks weird Caitlyn doesn't look ugly
over yeah she's fine bro I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie to you she's got a set
of teeth on her
she's got a couple I'm just being
perfectly transparent she's got a couple
molars the two fronts the two front
molars yeah they cause her lips some
issues yeah
but they're glistening white teeth yeah
and she's Pang yeah especially when she
does her makeup yeah Jesus she's got a
fatty as well undercover fatty they
don't chat about it
they don't they don't even mention it
because you've got undercover yeah yeah
yeah
she's not a bad looking girl he gunned
for her damn and then at the commitment
ceremony Mother's Day
what's wrong he said I'm a monster and
I'm tapped yeah
was like cool how are you gonna make it
better hmm and he was like
um this in front of everyone in front of
everyone now how are you gonna make it
what are you gonna do to make it up to
her a man said I have some flowers he
said big man what are you gonna do
to make up for what you said to her and
he's like I'll give her a hug or like
that expert said
you're good you're gone same as I've
never done it before I just did it two
minutes ago somehow I'm doing it again
yeah yeah you're not you're not seeing
her again
yeah it was crazy wow it was crazy so
now we're moving forward
next episode I get to see this absolute
fire tie looking thing yeah who jumps in
Evelyn she seems like a [__] and this
new thing that Remsen is a monster
gang I'm excited okay so I get to see
them yeah and I get to see Claire
confess her sins okay so because
Harrison has left and he's no no
Harrison's not left
Shannon sorry Shannon sorry Santa got
turfed yeah so because Shannon got to
does his thing still does she have to go
as well the couple dips that's why this
new couple's coming in so two couples
have now dipped and we've got two new
couples coming in hey okay and um oh
yeah they can't get remarried obviously
he's married at first
two couples dip two couples coming back
okay Claire's gonna confess her sins and
I can't wait for her to get her
comeuppance did she actually get her
comeuppance
say less
oh yeah I say less okay I'm ready for it
okay because Jessie's the same trying to
remember Claire's face okay okay okay
okay she's bad okay um cool I'm excited
[__] clear all right I'm intrigued
for the next stop update all right cool
right man I've got a little tweeting
that I saw the other day yeah yeah that
spun my head and I wanted to read it out
so this is a chick
putting out an advert
for a man Strokes stepdad for her kids
okay bro so an advert an advert on
Twitter right okay so it says single mum
looking for a stepdad for my kids
qualifications
must have a six-figure salary
must have a car that can fit all my kids
comfortably or willing to buy an SUV or
a van
this is America right fam has to be
single dad will not be qualified
wow you can't have your own use wow I
have your own Utes
just mine the audacity willing to marry
me in less than a month
I will need to buy a 30 carat diamond
ring before the wedding what's going on
must be six foot or taller
must have a four to six bedroom
available for my kids
available for my kids must pay all the
rent or mortgages
you must pay all the red or mortgages
that's jokes must adopt all of my kids
oh my God that's pressure must know how
to cut grass must be good looking must
have six packs
she's polish this time must have at
least found must have at least 200k in
his bank account
to guarantee my kids future oh my God
must provide twice as much as the father
of my kid pays for child support what's
going on brother did I show a picture of
her or not she blurred it they better
off
they bloody better off
what
oh
who's applying for this role must have
must have
the mortgages the juice rent or
mortgages wow man said you need 200k to
guarantee my kids future they needed
four to six beds to fit all my kids I
need a four to six bed available
wow brother bravado it's the most
audacious thing I've ever seen in my
entire it's obviously for like clickbait
and stuff but if a man was to do that
kind of want list for a woman uh he will
get ran through not like that but you
know what I mean fast yes oh yeah yeah
if a guy put up an advert and was like
looking for ting I'm
looking for stepmom facilitator I'm
looking for yeah steps looking for
stepmom yeah can't have your own use no
if that was the first bullet point
Twitter's not letting go away they're
not Landing get past that first bullets
they're gonna have to they're gonna
force him to delete that they'll force
him to delete that tweet can't have your
own Utes
must be five foot two and or less it
must be five foot two or less must have
an hourglass figure yeah fake Double D's
fake double d flat stomach flat stomach
juicy Bay juicy Bay shakeable on
requests
shakeable request Manny Petty pattern
all the time
Manny Petty pound all the time bro must
clean well must cook better cook four
different meals for my four different
years facts must speak different
languages too facts I need a Spanish bad
B
like come on what world is this yeah the
world is born because that's hilarious
that mortgages thing is hilarious
mortgages
nah that's scary hours guaranteed my
kids future paid double what their dads
are paying
insane bro insane indeed anyway all
right we're going to mind the [__] to
finish yes sir am I the [__] for
breaking up with my ex am I the answer
for breaking up my ex with my new thing
slash her newting context me and this
girl have and have had an on and off
relationship for the better part of the
last three years
we decided to break it off for good and
be friends
to help move on I blocked on everything
and decided to start talking to this
co-worker
weeks after our weeks after the breakup
sorry I started getting texts from an
unknown number calling me a cheat and a
liar
after some quick back and forth I found
out it was my ex flipping out because
she found out I started talking to to
this next girl
I blocked the number only for her to get
a new number I'm continuing to harass me
and my co-worker calling her grimy and a
man stealer
we keep blocking her number or we keep
blocking her numbers until she got tired
I guess later later I found out the
reason for the Outburst was that my
co-worker had text my ex telling her we
have been dating and [__] for months
before we broke up wow which was a lie
that made me cut all ties with the
co-worker as well
mumps after months after I found out my
ex and my co-worker are now dating I
knew they were both bad but this caught
me off guard I tried to play it cool
when I see when I try to Clay cool when
I would see them at our workplace but I
was clearly upset
so I decided to unblock my ex and
started flirting and try to reconnect
she gave it now we [__]
throwback I told you one of them is weak
bro one of them's always weak what did I
say
what did I say bro making me sound like
I spice what did I say bro what did I
say bro you might not hearing me what
did I say bro
[__]
what did I say bro you might not killing
me here so
bro
laughs
that sucks
bro oh my God
[Applause]
don't see that again
bro
I spy speaks
oh
so it's one of the funniest ever things
that's ever happened on this show bro
that's one of the funniest things ever
happened to the show
how dare you
what to say bro no
fear hats oh gee
comedic Superstar oh [__]
Jesus let me run it back Mom saw after I
found out my ex and my co-worker are now
dating I knew um I knew they were both
by but this caught me off guard I tried
to play it cool when I fight when I
would see them at our workplace but I
was clearly upset so I decided to
unblock my ex start flirting and try to
re reconnect she gave it now we [__]
now she broke up with the co-worker am I
the Arsenal for breaking them up because
I was jealous
so quick recap
guy was with his
um guy was an on and off relationship
with a thing for three years they locked
it off they just wanted to be friends he
started talking to a co-worker and he
started getting unknown messages from
his ex calling him a chi and liar
decided to block it thought it was
moving brazy
another number started texting him again
is thinking what's going on and he was
texting the co-worker as well
and it's like what the [__] they both
blocked her and
um
the co-worker and his ex now started
dating yep
moving forward moving forward moving
forward he clocked that they were but he
knew that they were but I didn't think
that they were going to ever link or
ever meet she brings the ting to his
workplace he's obviously feeling some
type of way he tries to reconnect with
his ex unblock the number started
talking again she gave in they banged
he's asking now they've broken up
co-worker and X should is he the [__]
for breaking them up
considering the whole situation
considering the whole situation I'd
actually say no you know yeah it's
strangely enough it's a different one
you say no bro because that whole thing
is braces that whole thing is brazy but
actually no he is a bit of an [__]
because it sounds like his X was
actually the innocent one in this
situation because she was so nice
he was fertilized by the co-worker by
the co-worker yeah yeah
um
so yeah she was fertilized by the
co-worker but then again she's an
[__] for dating his Ting anyway
they're all awesome they're all awesome
you're not the [__] only because you
are equally as much of an [__] as the
whole Trio all 33 you collectively make
an Arsenal yeah yeah yeah all three of
you collectively you you make the whole
quadrants yeah yeah so there you go so
there you go bro wow we I can't believe
how funny that was I can't believe how
funny that was if you had bro thank you
so much for being you I'm not even
playing with you bro there isn't another
person that on this planet that would
get me to laugh that hard
just off the clock bro there isn't a
person that breathes that would make me
laugh that hard
to say bro you don't get it bro that's
funny
oh wow
funny bro
Jesus wet wow guys thank you so much bro
I'm not gonna lie because that ending is
top three endings of any podcast I've
ever done bro so guys thank you so much
if you made it this far thank you for
sticking around obviously hit us up on
patreon patreon.com shits and gigs and
join one of the biggest cultures on this
planet
and for the rest of you guys love love
love
[Music]
foreign